it's gonna be the most explosive season
I've ever experienced we are getting
flown exactly where we do not want house
quarantine life treating a captain sandy
you know let's just say I've been taking
advantage of the outdoors I was gonna
say you're landlocked a bit right now
and foreseeable future we don't really
know what yachting is gonna look like
still gonna happen
the one thing that happens on yachts is
isolation this is true and the one thing
that happens on your yacht is a film
crew captures everything and we're
headed into season five of below deck
Mediterranean how are you feeling about
season five you know I'm excited I'm
thrilled
I can't wait to witness what the crew
are up to below deck more excuse me off
the less I wouldn't do I don't think
your attitudes very good to be together
and be nice stop talking I'm not how
much of what we see on TV winds up
surprising you is it like 50/50 Oh 80% I
mean seriously as we live and work
together and if I was always downstairs
in their business
hi first of all I don't really care
secondly you know then they can't be
themselves so many times I've walked
down to the crew stairs and heard
something and decided to walk back up
the stairs I always say this to the crew
if you can't work it out amongst each
other
then it comes to me that's usually the
end of someone's job I could have fired
you a long time ago Hannah
[Music]
it seems like things are gonna come to a
head with you and Hanna this year
now maybe we reach the breaking point of
Sandy and Hannah's relationship you know
what someone you know constantly you
know just goes against Authority or you
know you'll find out just like I will
just how it turns out with Hanna I buy
we all know she wants to be not doesn't
have some babies you know and she's
emitted Lee he's yawning you know so
when you have that mix it's kind of hard
to stay focused so I I wish had the best
of luck this season okay
she told me she's done after this season
this was her last season Amiens
does that surprise you she said that
every season do you have any crew say
that everyone at the end of this is me I
mean I don't live in Hannah's mine
thankfully but you know yeah I mean I
don't know like that's up to Hannah you
know so we get out of yachting and we
get back in the audience so many people
do well let's find out does it look like
there's gonna be some rockiness with
Hannah and with some of the other people
on board especially Seconds to Lara
seems to be quite the character and
Hannah actually told me she would prefer
to work with Chef Mila again over
working with Laura Wow
maybe don't touch me so in the trailer I
was like holy crap I had no idea was
practically a fistfight in the galley
you know I didn't know that Hannah
doesn't tell me these things
I think if Hannah would come to me more
often I could help her navigate this and
like I said I always say to creep you
can't work it out downstairs don't and
you bring it to me usually someone gets
fired do you think I would have fired in
that case probably okay so I don't you
know to me it's like just bring me your
problem because when it comes to someone
threatening you it crossed the line
they've crossed the line we don't do
that and I get rid of them I terminate
immediately
there's no threatening three members yes
one person has to sleep with her eye
open
if this really is Hannah's last season
is there anybody from seasons past you
would like to see come back and be chief
stew in the future on your yachts I'd
like to see a male she's you know it's
always cuz you know what I love about
Bravo's they put females on deck what's
a male's interior see how well they do
hi captains Andy welcome back it's very
cool to see Malia back on board and to
have below decks first female bosun what
did it mean to you to have Malia on
board as a bosun you know to have women
and female roles on a boat is great for
me you know cuz you know largely it's
men across the planet on yachts and
ships you know I I love it you know
Malia stepped off the vessel from the
season we filmed together and she went
and worked on yachts big yachts and she
got her captain's license and she has
constantly worked on yachts
so Malia's experience she's bringing it
all right is there anything else we need
to know about season five before I let
you go it's gonna be the most explosive
season I've ever experienced and for me
the most rewarding at the end because
you know the boat was a huge challenge
for me the crew are always challenged
right so that's that comes with a
yawning like you know always if you
asked any captain in the industry what's
your biggest complaint they'll say crew
we know that that going into it but when
you have a challenging vessel on top of
everything else it makes it harder but
you know what at the end of the season
it's the most rewarding and you'll see
why is it rewarding because of the boats
or because of the people both you know
and is it explosive because of the boat
or because of the people people people
the boats not explosive when those
things get explosive on the boat then we
got a problem
[Music]